between the star-studded cast and a plot
that sounds more like a dark character
study than your average superhero
adventure director Todd Phillips his
take on the iconic villain is one of the
more highly anticipated movies of 2019
here's a look at the untold truth of
Joaquin Phoenix's Joker as revealed by
cast members Ozzy beats the movie was
rewritten as it was filmed during an
interview with MTV beats went into
detail about the filming process we
rewrote the whole thing while we were
shooting it literally we would go into
Todd's trailer and write the scene for
the night and do it
the frequent rewrites and reshoots
suggest a much more improvisational
approach than most comic book movie
directors take which isn't necessarily a
bad thing it implies that the final
product will be a more collaborative
work incorporating ideas from the cast
into the director's vision
although Phillips's approach is unusual
it isn't without precedent Ironman for
instance was also written and further
developed as it was filmed
according to Jeff Bridges who played
antagonist Obadiah Stane the entire
project was based around an outline
Bridges and Robert Downey jr. would
improvise their way through scenes under
the guidance of director Jon Favreau and
their trailers while the crew waited on
set if Iron Man was shot in such a loose
manner and still turned out to be the
smash hit that launched the MCU there's
definitely hope for Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker in a rather unexpected move Warner
Brothers brought on Todd Phillips as
director producer and co-writer for the
film although Phillips is a veteran
filmmaker he's best known for raunchy
comedies such as the hangover trilogy so
it will be interesting to see how he
fares creating a much darker and more
serious film the studio has promised
Phoenix's Joker will be a gritty
low-budget character study quite a
departure from the light-hearted
slapstick comedies he's worked on before
don't be afraid to ride the lightning
[Music]
the closest that Philips has come to
working on this type of film before was
when he wrote produced and directed
2016's war dogs although that movie was
an action comedy that touched on some
darker elements of human nature it's
already clear from the few glimpses
we've had a Phoenix as Joker that this
new project is going deeper and darker
than any affiliate while keen Phoenix
was a pretty major casting coup for
Joker but he isn't the only impressive
name going before the cameras for the
film an equally unexpected addition
Robert DeNiro who's portraying a talk
show host who plays a role in setting
Joker down the path that turns him into
the sociopathic clown we all know and
love to hate one of the reasons this
role may have appealed to DeNiro is
because the script is reminiscent of a
movie he'd previously starred in the
King of Comedy in that film
De Niro played a mentally unhinged and
wildly unsuccessful comedian who kidnaps
a talk-show host in order to get his big
break this sounds eerily similar to the
premise of the Joker origin movie only
Phoenix will be playing the deranged
aspiring comic and DeNiro may be the one
getting kidnapped this time
Marc Maron has also joined the cast as a
talent agent who presumably works
alongside De Niro's character and za z
beets has also joined the cast as a
single mother who catches the Joker's
eye Todd Phillips elected to film on
location in New York which meant
seemingly anyone with a camera and the
Big Apple took a shot at trying to snap
photos of Phoenix and his co-stars in
costume
Phillips found himself becoming
increasingly annoyed by the paparazzi
taking grainy photos from whatever
long-distance angle they could muster so
he decided to cut out the middleman and
put out several high quality photos
himself when a few fans commented that
they were seeing too much of the movie
before it was even released Phillips
responded and explained his reasoning
behind releasing the images we have
paparazzi all over our set at every turn
and it bums me out that they constantly
put out their bad shots so I figured may
as well put out some good ones Jared
Leto is still slated to star in his own
standalone Joker film despite the
backlash over his first appearance
the character in Suicide Squad which
means there will be two different
iterations of the villain on screens
around roughly the same time it's
unusual for a studio to pit actors
against each other this way but there is
a twist they might not be the same Joker
Phoenix is in his mid-40s
which means what Keynes Joker will
already be approaching middle age when
his origin story unfolds since it's been
confirmed that Bruce Wayne's father will
play a role in the film
this suggests Phillips's story takes
place when Bruce himself is just a child
the age difference is important to note
because by the time Bruce Wayne would be
old enough to start patrolling the
streets of Gotham as Batman Joaquin's
Joker would be something like 60 or 70
since Batman and Joker are typically
assumed to be around the same age some
fans have suggested that Joaquin's
iteration of the character might serve
as inspiration for the Joker that Batman
faces later on despite being nominated
for three Oscars
Joaquin Phoenix found himself there
really intimidated by the idea of
playing the Joker which is one of the
main reasons he ultimately ended up
signing on for the project even though
Phoenix has a wide variety of experience
playing everything from a famous
musician to a paranoid Emperor and past
roles he admitted to being terrified by
the idea of portraying one of the most
iconic villains of all time
[Music]
this isn't the first time Phoenix is
contemplated playing a comic-book
character as he was one of the main
actors being considered for the role of
dr. strange he ended up passing on the
role saying he was worried that a
blockbuster film run by a huge studio
would restrict his freedom as an actor
which suggests this Joker will be a one
and done deal for its star another
reason Phoenix ended up agreeing to star
in Joker was the fact that he quickly
became enthralled with Phillips's vision
of a completely new take on a familiar
comic-book villain since there have been
so many different iterations of the
Joker over the years some critics were
wary of yet another one on the big
screen we've even seen several versions
of the Joker's origin story
but Phoenix remains optimistic about the
project because it's unlike any other
version of the Joker audiences have seen
before
he said I wouldn't quite classify this
as like any genre I wouldn't say it's a
superhero movie or a studio movie it
feels unique and I think more than
anything and probably the most important
thing is Todd seems very passionate
about it and very giving so that's
exciting without the presence of Batman
or other widely known comic book
characters besides the Joker himself
this film is already headed in a very
different direction and we haven't even
seen what else Phillips might have up
his sleeve the first images of Phoenix
in costume revealed the grubby make up
he would be wearing as the Joker and
offered some insight into some of the
inspirations for this version of the
Clown Prince of Crime although at first
glance the makeup design definitely
seems reminiscent of Heath Ledger's
Joker
upon further examination it also seems
to draw inspiration from several other
sources the color palette used certainly
seems inspired by the makeup borne by
John Wayne Gacy a serial killer in the
70s who worked as a clown at parties and
events
Casey's clown makeup also incorporated
the wide red mouth and the high blue I
paint that appears on Phoenix the bright
blue makeup around the eyes also seems
to be a nod to the look that the Joker
had in some of the older Batman comics
such as The Laughing fish and sign of
the Joker making movies might seem
glamorous but those days on the set can
be long and difficult according to TMZ
conditions on Joker took a turn for the
worse in October 2018 when the cast was
filming on location in a Brooklyn subway
station apparently a group of extras
were actually locked inside a subway car
for hours since they'd been locked
inside the train car for so long that
they needed to use the bathroom some
extras resorted to urinating on the
train tracks between cars just to
finally get some relief
upon receiving complaints about the
incident the Screen Actors Guild sent a
representative to handle the situation
and monitor Philips is set for the rest
of the shoot in interviews Joaquin
Phoenix has suggested that Joker won't
be the typical adrenaline spiking CGI
filled action film that DC and Marvel
fans are accustomed to
instead the studio plans to deliver a
low-budget character study as it turns
out Phoenix had actually discussed a
similar idea several years before he
heard a joker origin movie was in the
works three or four years ago called my
agent and said why not they want to take
one of these characters and just make a
lower budget film about a movie but a
character study and why not take one of
the villains although Phoenix's agent
tried to convince him to attend a
general meeting with Warner Brothers
after this talk Phoenix dismissed the
idea he even forgot about the entire
concept until he heard about Phillips is
filmed realized it was exactly the type
of role he'd been imagining based on the
brief descriptions of the script cast in
some set photos there's ample
speculation that Joker will be taking
inspiration from a comic considered one
of the greatest Joker stories of all
time The Killing Joke although it won't
be a direct adaptation several core
elements from the comic storyline could
be carried over written by Alan Moore
it's one of the best and most widely
acclaimed Joker stories and the
beginning sounds very similar to the
premise of Joaquin Phoenix's Joker just
like Phoenix's character Arthur Fleck
the Joker in The Killing Joke started
out as a failed and frustrated stand-up
comedian he got a funny shaped head
maybe I should have been a clown instead
of a comedian as the story progresses
he's transformed into the Joker in an
accident after getting involved in a
robbery with some shady characters in
order to support his pregnant wife
given that zazzy beats is playing a
single mother who Phoenix's character
Falls for it stands to reason that this
Joker might also start down a dark path
in an attempt to provide for a woman and
her child
another Killing Joke connection comes
from some of the first set pictures
which show an area that resembles
amusement Mile
of Gotham City that appears in the comic
Phoenix has gained a reputation for
undergoing dramatic transformations such
as when he played Johnny Cash and walked
the line or Jesus Christ and Mary
Magdalene when preparing for his role as
the Joker he once again faced a physical
challenge in order to emulate the
traditionally scrawny villain the actor
had to slim down considerably
Joker co-stars Ozzy beats revealed that
Phoenix's weight loss was so significant
that it actually limited the potential
for reshoots after the production
completed filming we had to do
everything then because Joaquin and lost
so much weight that we couldn't do
reshoots later on even though drastic
physical transformations can take a
serious toll on an actor's health comes
as no surprise that a performer so
legendary and dedicated to his craft
would go above and beyond to completely
transform into his character check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about all things
DC are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]